[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit
kaiselver richichter und Christian
sieas guten Abend viele hier in
Deutschland trauern heute um einen der
so etwas war wie das Gedächtnis dieser
Republik einer der die Schaltstellen der
Macht und das Herz unserer Demokratie
aus allen erdenklichen Blickwinkeln
kannte der am längsten amtierende
Abgeordnete in der deutschen
Parlamentsgeschichte ist tot er hat die
Politik in diesem Jahr in den letzten 50
Jahren so geprägt wie kaum ein anderer
und das obwohl er weder Bundeskanzler
noch Bundespräsident war und damit ist
bereits viel gesagt über das Leben von
Wolfgang Schäuble voller politischer
Errungenschaften und und voller
Rückschläge ein Architekt der deutschen
Einheit der nur neun Tage nach dem
großartigsten Moment seines Schaffens
fertig werden musste mit der Diagnose
nie wieder gehen zu können an all das
denken wir heute und werden wir heute
erinnert Wolfgang Schäuble wurde 81
Jahre alt der Nachruf von Andreas
künerst er war ein Mann für die langen
Strecken 51 Jahre war Wolfgang Schäuble
Mitglied des Bundestags VI 5 Jahre
verheiratet 58 Jahre in der CDU ich bin
ein treuer Mensch das sagt sogar meine
Frau Treue ist etwas ganz Wesentliches
im menschlichen Leben es sind Schäubles
Ausdauer und seine Treue die ihn nach
oben bringen als Kanzleramtsminister
legt er für Helmut Kohl Konflikte und
Affären bei als Innenminister verhandelt
er die deutsche Einheit mit der
Unterzeichnung des einigungsvertrags
erklärt die DDR ihren Beitritt zum
Rechtsgebiet der der Bundesrepublik
Schäubles
Meisterstück dann der 12 oktober
1990 nach einer Wahlkampfrede in Oppenau
schießt ein psychisch kranker Mann
Schäuble ins Gesicht und in den Rücken
lange ist unklar ob der Minister
überlebt eine Wunde war hier da ist ein
einstchuss der ging hier so durch der
ganze halbe Kiefer war weg und dann
werden Sie also so mit Strohalm
flüssiger Nahrung ein bisschen ernährt
und können sich nicht rühren und tut
alles weh Schäuble kämpft sich zurück in
sein Leben und das heißt in die Politik
als die CDU
1998 die Bundestagswahl verliert wird
Schäuble Parteichef aber schon kurz
danach zerstört die Spendenaffäre nicht
nur den Ruf von Helmut Kohl sondern auch
eine jahrzehntelange politische
Partnerschaft wenn ich dem Helm Kohl
versöhn mich versöhnen soll müssen wir
drüber Ausreden worüber wir uns
versöhnen und es geht ungefähr eine
halbe Minute ein den größten Krach der W
ich ih se ich bin ja nicht mehr bös ja
du brauchst mir gar nicht bös sein ich
habe ja nichts gemacht doch und das hat
keinen Sinn deswegen habe GT lass es
doch lass es das auch Schäuble einen
Aktenkoffer voll Geld von Waffenhändler
Karlheinz Schreiber angenommen hat
verschweigt er dem Parlament bei dieser
Veranstaltung bin ich ein Schreiber
begegnet so das
war's ohne Koffer also vielle ich habe
Aktenkoffer vielleicht dabei weiß ich
zwei Monate später tritt Schäuble zurück
Angela Merkel übernimmt die CDU aber
Schäuble kommt wieder erst als innen
dann als Finanzminister in der Eurokrise
legt sich scheubble mit Griechenland an
und mit Kanzlerin Merkel denn gegen den
Willen seiner Chefin droht der
Finanzminister Athen mit Rausschmiss aus
dem Euro am
284 als Bundestagspräsident beschäftigt
Sch dieunehmende Polarisierung der
Republik seine Mahnung richtet sich an
alle
Parteien die Art wie wir hier
miteinander reden die kann vorbildlich
sein für die gesellschaftliche Debatte
brügeln sollten wir uns hier nicht ich
persönlich verliere mit Wolfgang
Schäuble den engsten Freund und Ratgeber
den ich in der Politik jemals hatte vor
nicht mal einem Monat fängt die Kamera
noch einmal sch ein da ist er 81 ganz
offensichtlich guter Dinge und immer
noch treu seinem Leben der Politik
Ulrich Reiz ist chefkorrespondent von
FOCUS Online und er hat eine Biografie
geschrieben über Wolfgang Schäuble hat
ihn lange begleitet Herr Reiz guten
Abend guten Abend gibt's eine Begegnung
ein Erlebnis das diesen Ausnahme
poliitiker für sie beschreibt also etwas
D sie nicht vergessen werden ja in der
hat M es war 1994 im März schäule war
Fraktionsvorsitzender der Union und nach
New York gereist ich durfte mit und an
dem Samstag hat er mich eingeladen ihn
zu begleiten ins guggenheimmuseum n muss
man wissen das guggenheimmuseum ist so
eine Schnecke und da geht's dann hoch
und Schäuble stand mit seinem Rollstuhl
unten und plötzlich sauste er los und
fuhr diese Schnecke herauf und ich hatte
die Eingebung
dass er das nicht schaffen würde da
hochzukommen und also bin ich sozusagen
ähm direkt hinterher gelaufen links
davon der Bodyguard von Schäuble und
Schäuble wurde immer langsamer und auf
einmal blieb er mitten auf dieser
Schnecke stehen und
wir haben sozusagen in diesem Moment
zugegriffen und den Rollstuhl nach oben
geschoben das war eine schwierige
demütigende Situation für Scheuble als
wir oben waren hat er sich nicht
umgeguckt und den ganzen Tag über diese
Situation nie gesprochen und auch später
nicht mehr er war ein harter Mann der
sich selber viel abverlangt hat und auch
anderen viel abverlangt hat und diese
demütigende Situation die er da erlebt
hat weil er ohne eigenes Zutun diese
Hürde nicht geschafft hat die werde ich
nicht vergessen es zeigt aber doch auch
dass erst zunächst einfach mal versuchen
wollte und dass er ja immerhin auch die
Hälfte oder über die Hälfte dieses
Gebäudes geschafft hat wo manche die da
hoch laufen auser Puste
kommen da haben sie auch wieder recht
sie was nein Schle war ein ein Kämpfer
er hat sich überhaupt nichts erspart ich
meine erinnern Sie sich an die Zeit nach
dem Attentat 9un Tage nach der
staatlichen Wiedervereinigung
Deutschlands ist er mit zwei Schüssen
aus der Waffe des Psychopathen Dieter
Kaufmann niedergestreckt worden in der
Gaststätte Bruder in opnau
und seine Heilung oder seine teilheilung
hat er öffentlich zelebriert es waren
häufig Kameras dabei und er wollte
diesen öffentlichen Kampf zeigen und er
wollte zeigen wozu er fähig war es war
Teil seiner Therapie sie haben schon
angesprochen das ist ja ein ein
unfassbares nebeneinander zwischen
großem Erfolg und wirklich furchtbarem
Schicksalsschlag wenn man sich
schäubbleles Leben anguckt greifen wir
aus den vielen Daten vielleicht noch
einen anderen hervor der der
erfreulicher ist der 20 Juni 1991
nämlich ein Tag den ich zumindest in
Zusammenhang mit neu mit mit Wolfgang
schäubel nicht vergessen werde 18
Stimmen machten den Unterschied damals
bei der Frage soll Bonn oder Berlin
Hauptstadt und Regierungssitz des wier
vinten Deutschlands werden den echten
Unterschied macht aber Schubel der die
Rede seines Lebens hält einer der ja
weder aus Berlin kam noch aus dem
Rheinland wie viel hat denn Berlin
Schäuble da zu verdanken alles deswegen
ist Berlin hat Berlin ihn auch zum
Ehrenbürger der Stadt ernannt bei dieser
Rede war es so dass Schäuble
unvorbereitet ans Rednerpult gerollt ist
und hat wie sie sagen die Rede seines
Lebens gehalten die wichtigste Rede in
seiner Karriere und hat praktisch im
Alleingang die Entscheidung des
Parlaments zugunsten der von Berlin als
bundeshauptstattt herbeigeführt man muss
wissen die haben da diskutiert über die
Frage was wie sicher sind Arbeitsplätze
äh haben wir hier regionale
Strukturpolitik was wird aus Bonn und so
weiter und da ging schäupble ans
Rednerpult und sagte jetzt lass mal
diesen ganzen Kleinkram Weg es geht hier
nicht um Arbeitsplätze es geht hier
nicht um Struktur oder Regionalpolitik
sondern es geht um die Zukunft
Deutschlands und nach dieser Rede die ja
nur einige Minuten dauerte nach dieser
Rede haben sich alle die für Bonn waren
auf einmal furchtbar klein gefühlt
gefühlt und man muss wissen es war ein
halbes Jahr nach dem Attentat auf
Schäuble und man hatte diesem Heron
zugeschaut wie er genesen war und jetzt
ist er bei dieser wichtigen Rede Willi
Brand stand danach auf Ehrenvorsitzender
der SPD ging zu Wolfgang Schäuble
schüttelte ihm die Hand und völlig klar
war in diesem Moment hatte bon die
Schlacht verloren wenn Friedrich März
der cduf heute sagt er habe sein engsten
Freund und Ratgeber verloren den er in
der Politik je hatte dann zeigt das
natürlich einerseits wie selten echte
Freundschaft offensichtlich ist in der
in der Politik es zeigt aber auch wie
sehr Wolfgang Schäuble aktuell immer
noch mitspielt oder schäble hat bis
zuletzt aktuell noch mitgespielt
Friedrich machz hat in einer der letzten
Fraktionssitzungen Schäuble gefragt ob
er zu dem Karlsruher schuldenuchteil
eine Bemerkung machen wollte und es war
ein typischer schäuple den wir dann
hören konnten er hat nämlich gesagt
irgendwann wir werden wir selbst auch
mal wieder regieren nach dem Motto
ergeht euch nicht in Triumphgefühl und
freut euch nicht zu früh irgendwann
werden euch die Folgen eurer eigenen
Entscheidung diesen Schuldenhaushalt der
Bundesregierung der ampelregierung
anzugreifen selber einholen wenn ihr
wieder in Verantwortung seid ein
typischer Schäuble die hatten erwartet
dass er ihnen Anlass gibt zu jubeln auch
zu zu triumphgefühlen gegenüber der
ampelregierung und er hat das Gegenteil
getan er hat sie ermahnt in drei Worten
vielleicht heriz was wird der deutschen
Politik jetzt ohne Schäuble Fehlen der
letzte große konservative der letzte
große Werte Politiker von bürgerlichen
Werten einer der faszinierendsten Redner
den Deutschland je besessen hat und
einer der großen Demokraten der es
geschafft hat 14 Mal seinen Wahlkreis in
Offenburg direkt zu
erobern das ist wirklich eine absoluter
Meilenstein in der Demokratie Erlebnisse
mit Erinnerungen an Wolfgang Schäuble
von Ulrich Reiz herreiz vielen Dank für
das Gespräch gerne her sie was und das
haben wir aus Termingründen vor einer
dreffelstunde aufgezeichnet eine
ausführliche Würdigung von Wolfgang
Schäuble sendet das ZDF gleich nach uns
hier heute
abend es bleibt jetzt erstmal weitgehend
trocken das ist die wichtige Botschaft
der Meteorologen heute besonders für
alle die Bang auf die Pegelstände
schauen das heißt nämlich die
Hochwasserlage kann sich an einigen
Flüssen entspannen anderswo so etwa an
der Elbe in Sachsen und SachsenAnhalt
bleibt sie kritisch Stefan Kelch hat die
Übersicht und beginnt in
Thüringen das Wasser verschwindet
langsam aus Windehausen erste Bewohner
kommen ammittag schauen was es
angerichtet hat trauriges Fazit von
Tobias Schulze kann ich alles
rausreien muss alles raus verschwindet
das Wasser tauchen die Probleme auf die
jüngst erneuerten Gasheizungen wieder
kaputt hochwasserversicherungen hat kaum
einer zu oft steht hier Wasser in den
Kellern da kriegt man keine
genau Versicherung will ja versichern
und verdienen wenn es öfter passiert
wird das nicht mal geben viele
Dorfbewohner sind bei der Feuerwehr für
sie gab es kein Weihnachten Stefan
Schmidt bricht es das Herz wenn er an
seine Tochter denkt die selbst mit im
Einsatz ist ihre Geschenke zog er zu
Hause aus dem Wasser ich wollte sie ja
überreden schon mein Geschenk
zwischendurch auszupacken hat sieesagt
ne
Papa erst soll alles wieder in Ordnung
kommen und wenn es bis Ostern dauert was
gut sein kann denn noch gibt es hier
nicht einmal Strom mit dem man das
Aufräumen beginnen
könnte mit einem blauen Auge wird
Dresden davon kommen wenn alles bleibt
wie vorher gesagt die Scheitelwelle
rollt ab morgen früh an der Elbestadt
vorbei bei etwas über 6 m zwar imposant
aber nicht gefährlich mit dem Pegel 6 m
der dann wahrscheinlich morgen hier in
Dresden erreicht wird schalten wir dann
um in den Wachdienst das heißt also da
wird dann über den gesamten Tag über
eine Wache an den Deichen verort sein um
zu schauen dass die Deich in Ordnung
sind aber kein Vergleich mit den
Hochwassern 2002 und 2013 da war der
Pegel bei über 9
m das ist eigentlich normal für uns also
unter 6 m ist kein Problem so schlimm
wird es nicht wir haben
vorgesorgt die Fluttore geschlossen die
Elbbrücken werden zur Loge überm
Hochwasser das ist bislang keine Gefahr
nur für den Weihnachtszirkus am Elbufer
ist erstmal Schluss der muss sehen dass
er seine Zelte überhaupt noch abgebaut
bekommt am präziner W bei Magdeburg
sammeln sich schon heute die
Schaulustigen obwohl es erst morgen
geöffnet werden soll erstmals wieder
seit 10 Jahren ich komme ja aus der
Gegend bin hier groß geworden eigentlich
ja man kennt es von damals da war es ja
regelmäßiger als jetzt aber es ist jetzt
schon was besonderes geworden unsere
Hochwasserschutzanlagen werden ja besser
und und werden ja erneuert also für uns
ist es weniger geworden an Gefahr die
wir spüren das Wehr soll Magdeburg
schützen wird aber die Felder unterhalb
des wehes überschwemmen auch eine
Bundesstraße ist dann nicht mehr
passierbar aber auch hier wird es wohl
in ein paar Tagen heißen mit dem
Schrecken noch einmal davon
gekommen so jetzt du mit einem ersten
Überblick über das was heute auch noch
wichtig ist und mit einer Zahl die
aufhorchen lässt die Bundesregierung hat
dieses Jahr so viele Rüstungsexporte
genehmigt wie noch nie laut
Wirtschaftsministerium hatten sie einen
Gesamtwert von rund 11,7 Milliarden Euro
mehr als ein Drittel ging an die Ukraine
auch in den arabischen Raum wurden
wieder Lieferungen erlaubt was wegen der
Menschenrechtslage umstritten ist
eigentlich wollte die Ampelkoalition die
Rüstungsexporte eindämmen mit Russlands
Angriff auf die Ukraine kam da die
kertwende viele Patienten standen heute
vor verschlossenen Türen denn in ganz
Deutschland streiken die
niedergelassenen Ärzte damit wollen sie
Druck auf die Gesundheitspolitik machen
viele öffnen erst wieder am 2 Januar die
Mediziner fordern ein neues
Honorarsystem und den Abbau von
Bürokratie im Januar soll es dazu einen
Krisengipfel geben zum erzstreik äußert
sich Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach
nachher im heute journal
Update auch die Kliniken stehen unter
Druck laut der Deutschen
Krankenhausgesellschaft schrieben mehr
als Dreiviertel aller Krankenhäuser
dieses Jahr rote Zahlen knapp 40 Häuser
hätten Insolvenz angemeldet 2024 könnte
sich die Zahl verdoppeln als Hauptgrund
nannte Verbandschef Gast dem
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland
gestiegene Personalkosten und die
Inflation in Polen hat die neue
Regierung angekündigt den
öffentlichrechtlichen rundfun formell
aufzulösen und ihn dann neu zu
strukturieren vor einer Woche hatte sie
bereits die komplette führungsrieger
abgesetzt unter dem Protest von
Anhängern der Vorgängerregierung die
Nationalkonservativen hatten die
Medienfreiheit immer mehr eingeschränkt
und die Anstalten zu ihrem Sprachrohr
gemacht sie sollen nun wieder unabhängig
berichten
können die New York Times hat eine
Milliardenklage gegen open ai und
Microsoft erhoben um deren chatboard
Chat GPT zu trainieren hätten sie
mehrere Millionen Artikel der Zeitung
verwendet damit hätten sie massiv
Urheberrechte verletzt und einen Schaden
von mehreren Milliarden Dollar
verursacht open ai müsse die gesammelten
Daten vernichten sollte die Klage
erfolgreich sein könnten andere
Medienunternehmen
Folgen Jacques Delor gilt als Architekt
der modernen EU nun ist er im Alter von
98 Jahren gestorben 1985 wechselte der
Franzose von Paris nach Brüssel 10 Jahre
lang leitete er dort die Kommission in
dieser Zeit wurde der EU Binnenmarkt
vollendet das Schengenabkommen
unterzeichnet und die Wirtschafts- und
Währungsunion gestartet damit bereitete
Delor auch dem Euro den
Weg der Krieg im Nahen Osten ist alles
andere als vorbei oder auch nur auf dem
Weg zu einem Ende israel setzt seine
Angriffe auf Gaza fort insbesondere im
Süden Armeechef herzichalwi sagt der
Krieg werde noch viele Monate dauern die
Situation an Israels Nordgrenze macht
zunehmend große Sorgen dort wachsen die
Spannungen zwischen Israel und der
schiitenmiliz hisbolla den
hamasmachthaber in Gaza scheint der weil
anders als den von ihnen regierten
Menschen in Gaza deren Lage katastrophal
ist weder Geld noch Ressourcen wirklich
auszugehen wie Susanna Santina aus Tel
Aviv
berichtet es war ein spektakulärer Fund
nach Angaben der israelischen Armee
wurden in einem Haus eines hamasführers
in jabalia in mehreren Koffern 5
Millionen Schäkel rund 1,2 Millionen
Euro gefunden und mit jedem Tunnel den
die Streitkräfte in Gasa entdecken wie
diesen bislang größten durch den
Fahrzeug über 4 km fahren können stellt
sich die Frage wie die Hamas das alles
finanzieren
konnte weil mehrere Staaten die
Terroristen seit Jahren unterstützen
sagt nizana dasan Leidner so habe die
Hamas jährlich mehr als eineinhalb
Milliarden Dollar zur
Verfügung f halbe Milliarde kommt von
Qatar zwischen einer halben und einer
Milliarde Dollar von der
palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde mehrere hundert
Millionen Dollar stellt Iran zur
Verfügung überraschend ist das nicht die
zwei hamasführer Hania und sinwa sind
gern gesehen in Qatar Hania lebt dort
sie treffen sich immer wieder mit den
politischen Führern des iranischen
Muller regims und denen der
palästinensischen
Autonomiebehörde doch auch die
israelische Regierung habe lange Zeit
Fehler gemacht sagt UDI Levi früherer
Mitarbeiter des mossat man habe sogar
geldlieferungen an die Hamas
zugelassen wir dachten damals wir
könnten mit der Hamas eine langfristige
Lösung finden das heißt wir lassen euch
in Ruhe wir werden euch nicht töten aber
ihr tut uns auch nichts an leider war
das ein großer
Fehler denn die Hamas rüstete sich
derweil weiter gegen Israel auf in Gaza
geht sie zur Zeit gegen ihre eigene
Bevölkerung vor beschlagnammt immer
wieder
Hilfsgüter und schießt auf Menschen weil
sie aus Not Lebensmittel von den LKW
mitnehmen
wollen nun denken Sie mal was passiert
wenn die Welt nicht so genau hinschaut
alle Hilfsgüter die nach Gaza gehen kann
die Hamas an sich nehmen sie entscheidet
was sie
braucht so erklärt sich auch wie die
Hamas über Jahre ein tnz Ben konnte
gedacht waren die Tonnen von Zement für
Häuser Krankenhäuser und
Schulen und für die Geldüberweisungen an
die Hamas ist nach Ansicht des
israelischen Geheimdienstes vor allem
die Türkei verantwortlich Präsident
erdogan hatte die Hamas Freiheitskämpfer
und Israel einen Terrorstaat genannt
heute sagt er über
netanahu welchen Unterschied gibt es zu
Hitler ohne die Türkei wäre es sehr sehr
komplizit für wie has an Geld zu kommen
weil das gesamte Geld das nach Gaza und
ins Westjordanland überwiesen wird über
die Türkei läuft über Geldwechsler und
Banken israel will die Hamas endgültig
besiegen solange sie von vielen Ländern
weiter finanziert werde sei das aber
kaum
möglich so jetzt hier noch mal du
kaiselwden mit einem Stimmungsbild aus
der deutschen Wirtschaft die Stimmung
dort hat sich dieses Jahr verdüstert 30
von 47 Branchenverbänden bewerten ihre
Lage schlechter als im Vorjahr das zeigt
eine Umfrage des arbeitgebernahen
Instituts der deutschen Wirtschaft
demnach erwartet rund die Hälfte der
Verbände dass es 2024 noch schwieriger
wird als wichtigen Grund nannte IV Chef
Hüter die Unsicherheit wegen der
Haushaltskrise ja das Sparprogramm der
Bundesregierung hat auch Folgen für uns
Verbraucher denn wir werden wohl bald
mehr für unseren Strom bezahlen müssen
und das trotz sinkender Preise im
Großhandel wie passt das zusammen wer
Haller das liegt daran dass der Bund
ursprünglich einen Zuschuss zu den
endgelten für das durchleiten von Strom
geplant hatte diesen aber aus
Spargründen gestrichen hat 5inhalb
Milliarden Euro waren angedacht und für
die netzbetreuber bedeutet das höhere
Kosten die sie vermutlich recht schnell
an die Kunden weitergeben damit steigen
die Netzentgelte im kommenden Jahr
deutlich das schlägt sich in der
Stromrechnung nieder für einen
durchschnittlichen vier Personenhaushalt
bedeutet das wohl rund 120 € mehr pro
Jahr
laut Netzagentur ist Strom immer noch
deutlich teurer als vorausbruch des
ukrainekrieges und daran wird sich nach
Aussage der Behörde auch erstmal nichts
ändern jedenfalls nicht so lange noch
solange noch große Mengen Kohle Öl und
Erdgas zur Energiegewinnung im Einsatz
sind bleiben wir mal kurz beim Gas es
jaah ganz ähnlich trotz sinkender Preise
dürften die Verbraucher unterm Strich
bald mehr zahlen warum weil auch beim
Gas einige Erhöhungen anstehen den
größten Anteil dürfte die Mehrwertsteuer
haben die ab Februar von 7 wieder auf
19% angehoben wird außerdem erhöht sich
zum Jahreswechsel der CO2 Preis und dann
endet im kommenden Jahr noch die
energiepreisbremse für Strom und Gas und
laut dem Vergleichsportal Check 24
bedeutet das Gas dürfte kommendes Jahr
17% teurer werden danke an die Börse
Valerie 2023 war das wärmste Jahr in
Deutschland seit Beginn der
Wetteraufzeichnungen laut dem Deutschen
Wetterdienst lag die
Jahresmitteltemperatur bei
10,6° und damit noch mal 0,1° höher als
in den bisherigen Rekordjahren 2018 und
22 auch global wurde die bisher höchste
Durchschnittstemperatur gemessen sie lag
1,46° über dem Referenzzeitraum vor der
Industrialisierung das gab der EU
klimawandeldienst Kopernikus bekannt ja
vielen Tierarten macht nicht nur der
Klimawandel zu schaffen sondern auch die
Umweltverschmutzung oder die Zerstörung
ihrer Lebensräume laut dem WWF rollte
auch 2023 die Zitat größte
aussterbewelle seit Ende der
dinosaurierzeit praktisch ungebremst
über unsere Natur hinweg Verlierer des
Jahres seinen unter anderem Humbold
Pinguine Löwen und Flussdelfine in
Brasilien seien bei Wassertemperaturen
von knapp 40° etliche der Tiere
gestorben der WWF nennt aber auch
positive Entwicklungen so gebe es
erstmals seit Jahrzehnten wieder mehr
breitmaulen
maörner und dann haben wir noch die
Lottozahlen 6 9 17 33 41 44 Superzahl
ist die neun weitere Gewinnzahlen finden
Sie unter Lotto zdfde und im ZDF Text
auf Seite
557 das hier ist der
Eifelturm in Paris im Bilderrätsel wäre
selbst als Einstiegsfrage viel zu
einfach die Konstruktion war so
innovativ wie umstritten eine
abscheuliche Säule aus verschraubtem
Blech so stand es damals in der Zeitung
der Turm stand mehrfach kurz vor dem
Abriss heute undenkbar am 100 Todestag
seines Schöpfers feiert Frankreich
seinen Eifelturm Paris sein Wahrzeichen
Nummer 1 in einer an Wahrzeichen nicht
gerade Armen Stadt und sie feiern Gustav
eel den kühnen Konstrukteur aus Paris
Thomas Walde
grobe Nieten offene Strukturen diese
Bauwerke haben einen gemeinsamen Urheber
Brücken in Paris ebenso wie dieser
Turm man kann das den Ausdruck des
filigranen nennen des transparenten das
ein neues Konzept und Paradigma für die
Architektur bedeutet in jener Epoche
eine Architektur des Eisens die sehr neu
war sein symbolisches Erbe ist durch den
Eifelturm sichtbar aber tes Werk zieht
sich ein Glauben an den
Fortschritt sein bekanntestes Werk hat
Gustav eiifell zu großen Teilen selbst
finanziert zur Weltausstellung 1889
eiell musste es gegen Widerstände
durchsetzen vielen Künstlern und
Architekten galt der Turm der da höher
in den Himmel wuchs als alle anderen vor
ihm schlicht weg als
hässlich die Architekten verwendeten zu
jener Zeit Fassaden aus Stein mit
klassischem Dekor die Konstruktion
eifelds
1889 im Herzen von Paris eine
Konstruktion ganz aus Eisen schockierte
darum
viele vom ungeliebten Eisen zur meist
fotografierten Sehenswürdigkeit der Welt
bis heute spüren Besucher dass der
Eifelturm mehr ist als eine technische
Errungenschaft im Vergleich zu meiner
Erwartung dachte ich als ich ihn das
erste Mal wirklich sah na ja okay okay
aber als ich dann die Treppen hochging
änderte sich das all die Emotionen kamen
hoch eiifell musste selbst nach dem Bau
bangen zur nächsten Weltausstellung
sollte der Turm abgebaut werden das
Pariser Architekturmuseum zeigt wie
eiifell ih mit Experimenten das
Überleben
sicherte sehr bald installierte auf dem
Turm eine fallvorrichtung die es erlaubt
mit dem Luftwiderstand verschiedener
Materialien zu
experimentieren
Wissenschaft die fortwirkt das
laboreifell im 16 pariser Arrondissement
diesen Windkanal baute Gustav eiifell
für seine Experimente bis heute wird er
von industriellen und Architekten
genutzt er hat diese Tätigkeit für
Frankreich entwickelt und war der
Vorreiter zumindest in Frankreich heute
könnte man sich nicht vorstellen keine
Aerodynamik zu
haben so lebt weiter Jahre nach seinem
Tod mit einer Arbeit die nicht
Unterschied zwischen Schönheit und
nützlichem und vielleicht gerade deshalb
bis heute
leuchtet ja allerdings aktuell nur von
unten zu sehen ausgerechnet heute blieb
der Turm nämlich zu die Mitarbeiter
wollen Druck machen in den anstehenden
Tarifverhandlungen so viel von uns im
heute jonnal Update gibt's mehr und zwar
um :r mit nasan göckd n noch einen
schönen Abend
[Musik]
tschüss schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja rekordwarm wird
das Jahr weltweit wahrscheinlich das
Jahr 2023 und für Deutschland auch und
wir sehen hier den roten Balken der
alles übertrifft und und das ist das
Jahr 2023 das wärmste Jahr in
Deutschland seit
1881 ja und viel Regen und Schnee hatten
was in letzter Zeit und entsprechend
ging das mit viel Wärme in den Ozeanen
einher die zu warm waren und weiter
Regen folgt nicht ganz so viel es ist
eine kurzfristige Beruhigung mit 35
Leder in der Spitze im Nordwesten aber
die westliche Lage bleibt bestehen und
so kommt neuer Regen auf und diese kalte
Front die zieht im Tagesverlauf morgen
südwärts im Nordwesten teilweise Regen
in der Nacht nach Süden ist es trocken
teilweise Stern klar und eisig kalt bis
-2° hier 9° milild ganz im Westen
Deutschlands ja und morgen dann liegt
die Kaltfront erst ein meine Mitte dann
schwenkt sie nach Süden hin dann gibt's
Regen vom oberrehein bis ins Erzgebirge
ganz im Südosten ist es freundlich dann
auch nach Norden meist frereundlich nur
ganz im Nordwesten hier vor allem
Richtung Küste dann einige Schauer und
unterwegs bei höchsten Temperaturen von
6 bis 12° relativ mild ziemlich mild
geht's weiter auch am Freitag 7 bis 13°
weiter Regen teils aber sehr viel Wind
an den Küsten das Wochenende inklusive
Silvester dann nass und weiterhin Mels
einen schönen
Abend